sure everybody's been talking about
Alibaba from Silicon Valley to Wall
Street and why shouldn't they Alibaba is
pretty huge for starters it's the
world's largest e-commerce company last
year there were more than two hundred
and forty-eight billion dollars in
transactions on Alibaba sites
that's more than Amazon and eBay
combined more than 80 percent of all
e-commerce in China happens on an
Alibaba site and its IPO might be the
biggest in world history but those are
just numbers
what makes Alibaba even more interesting
is that this Chinese company can connect
you with millions of manufacturers
around the globe capable of making just
about anything so I wanted to put
Alibaba through its paces I wanted to
use the site to help me find a
manufacturer who could make me some fun
pants seemed like a pretty good idea to
reach those manufacturers I had to
create a buying request a form that
describes what I want to be made within
a day of posting my request I had
replies for manufacturers in China India
Pakistan and the Czech Republic to
whittle that list of manufacturers down
I first ditched any replies from
companies that weren't Alibaba gold
suppliers gold is a tier manufacturers
compete for it also means they've
submitted to some background checks to
ensure they're not running a scam among
the remaining companies I judge their
responses on basics like price and
delivery times but also on how
well-written their responses were and
other things like whether they included
a picture of some pants it's a little
bit like online dating ultimately I
decided to work with a manufacturer in
Pakistan now I know what you're thinking
how could I be sure these suppliers
weren't a bunch of sweatshops
I checked with the US Department of
Labor's international labor affairs
Bureau which tracks labor abuses around
the globe and they gave this project a
clean bill of health so to get started
my guy in Pakistan needs to get some
money this can happen in a couple of
different ways
Alibaba has an escrow service called Ali
pay which holds your money and only
releases it to the manufacturer when
you're satisfied with what you've
ordered alternatively you can pay a
manufacturer directly using Western
Union or wire transfers how much money
are we talking about here well let's
start by considering what I'm asking for
I'm looking for pairs of pants in four
different colors in multiple size
combinations I want more than one of
each that right there gets me to 280
pairs of pants and at nine dollars a
pair my total cost is two thousand five
hundred and twenty dollars but my costs
didn't end there
getting the pants heirship to me would
cost another 1983 dollars that would get
my pants flown from Pakistan to New York
in about two days so how did it all go
remarkably simple it was like combining
a Craigslist ad with a giant 3d printer
25 days and $4,500 after I started this
process I got exactly what I was looking
for a whole big mess of pants and they
came out fine but what do I do now on
the one hand I have enough pants to last
me for the rest of my life or I could
share the room with 279 my closest
friends
a guarantee there isn't a pair on the
streets like them
you